[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
and i'm very
excited
nervous because on today's episode we
have
me grace how big i am the host and the
guest it's just me by myself me myself
and i with you yourself and you and
uh i've never done this before and it
feels very strange already but also
familiar
who knows uh this is happening like this
because not too deep with grace how big
me host and guest
is taking a hiatus
after this episode for a bit
the exact amount of time has not
been
determined
because
i have a hard time making concrete
decisions we'll get into all of that in
this episode um yeah we're taking a
hiatus for a little bit
and i thought before we did that i would
try something i've never done before
something i'm scared of but something
that
challenges me and also kind of excites
me because i've never done that which is
just talking
to you by myself there's no crutches
there's no safety nets however i am if
you're watching this on youtube um
i'm not in my normal office in my house
that i record in i'm down in palm
springs i had to come down here
for some things and the timing of it uh
was that this is where i'm recording the
final episode so it's kind of
appropriate i feel a little displaced
from where i normally am
um which kind of mirrors
emotionally and creatively how i'm
experiencing myself in the world
at this point in time
um
it's very fun down here because we don't
have any desks in the palm springs house
so i have all my things set up the way i
used to record youtube videos in hotel
rooms on a an ironing board right here
uh and then i have a dresser pulled over
to my right that has my laptop on it uh
and i have a half drink
can of red bull uh that doesn't really
change i am a bit over caffeinated and
still feel tired um
so this is
bound to be an incredible episode all
the way around
and she sips so
i
wanted to do this because i have
some thoughts about things and stuff
that
felt like this was the more appropriate
medium to kind of
explore them and say them out loud
instead of just constantly rattling them
around in my brain
and then i went on
good old
reliable
soul fulfilling social media
and i asked you guys if you had
any questions
or topics or things that you would be
interested on me touching on
and so i've incorporated
a lot of those questions and things that
you guys have asked into what i want to
talk about today
i didn't want this to feel scripted
but i did want to be prepared so i wrote
eight pages of notes here
and after i wrote these eight pages of
notes
i felt like i did it there you go
there's everything i need to say um but
then i haven't actually done it until
right now so we're gonna get into these
notes
uh
skillfully kind of crafted with your
suggestions and i thank you all so much
for them
so let's just do it this is me
rambling and bantering to avoid
just doing it
so
this i think is our 349th
episode i thought maybe 350 but not
quite but still
349 episodes of a podcast
um
that might be the time that it's
appropriate to take a bit of a hiatus a
bit of a break
not too deep started back in 2014
and now we're almost eight years later
and yeah
that's
when i realized it's time to take a
break um
that's how long it usually takes me to
come to the
full understanding that i'm a bit tired
and should
step away from something
a lot of you wanted to know why the
hiatus obviously first and foremost
to that i say why do we stop doing
anything
maybe we're tired it doesn't feel
great anymore someone told you to stop
which wasn't the case here
um
overall usually it's because your
relationship
with something
has changed maybe it's plateaued maybe
it's worsened maybe the balance in the
effort versus outcome versus the
experience of it is off in some way and
that's kind of where i'm at i've learned
that
examining our relationship
with
um people and things and the way we
exist in the world is becoming to me
clarifying is one of the most important
things to kind of analyze
and just forewarning that
this episode might
be kind of a stream of consciousness
kind of a ted talk kind of a pep talk
kind of a rant a rambling a soapbox
monologue um
but for me these are just some of my
thoughts and you can determine what
package
you're experiencing them in so let's get
into
i've already said we need to examine our
relationships and that's what we're
going to be doing throughout this
examining relationships with ourselves
with our family with the world with our
work
everything we engage in is about
nurturing
relationships with it
it's about the
the in the thing in between not not the
you or the thing necessarily the the ex
the thing you have with it
again uh some of this might not make any
sense to you i haven't done any
fine-tuning
this is just kind of first draft
thoughts
so let's segue into
one of the
more popular areas of conversation
to talk about which is
and was
my decision to go back to school if you
don't know i am currently in a graduate
program
um
which has recently changed its name it's
currently called
depth psychology and creativity
very cool very fun very exciting very
amorphous very what is that uh and i'm
kind of in the middle of it i'm i should
be finishing up by
the uh the fall this year which is wild
that it will have been two years i
decided
to take on this new uh
experience back in the summer of 2020
and a lot of you wanted to know about my
decision to go back to school
um
why i chose the program that i did et
cetera so
i
in the summer of 2020 i think a lot of
us
realized everything was a bit
out of control things were changing a
lot of
difficult to process
stuff was going on
and that's when i kind of
was able to really concretize for myself
that my relationship with my work was
just so off there was some imbalance
there was something
not fulfilling something very forced and
stuck and um
just uh wasn't the joy
wasn't there the way that it used to be
and
uh we talk so much about relationships i
have a hard time recognizing when a
relationship is a little imbalanced
because i am a codependent libra and
when i'm in a relationship with anything
i will use my hyper anxiety mind
thoughts to try to force it to work out
i'll just think about the fact in a
relationship that something feels off
and i'll just loop those anxiety
thoughts over and over and over and over
and over thinking that maybe that'll fix
it you know
just that uh
that amount of effort will probably fix
it and i will tell you that i've had a
zero percent success rate with that
method
but it doesn't stop me from trying it is
my default go-to uh but that summer 2020
i finally decided to try
something different i needed
structure i needed
an intellectual challenge i needed to
kind of broaden
the bubble that i had been
not so peacefully existing in
which is how i found this step
psychology and creativity program i've
always been interested in psychology but
i knew
that i didn't want to get into clinical
psychology i didn't want to go into
advertising i didn't want to
go into corporate psychology which lands
you in some sort of hr type of
department
um
i think maybe the underlying thing is i
just didn't want to deal with other
people which is important to recognize
in your introverted self
but i wanted to study
creativity which i felt like i had
used to have such a beautiful blossoming
relationship with and just had felt like
it was
you know round peg square hole for me
and creativity and how you gonna [ __ ]
with that you can't
it hurts
so i found depth psychology and
creativity and it kind of touched on a
lot of things that i was interested in
learning about
while still maintaining a creative
environment in which i could dabble in
making things and processing
academic information artistically
which is what i've been doing a lot of
people wanted to know
what is it like being
in a graduate program what's it like
going back to school after not being in
school for a decade and i'm sure a lot
of you out there are currently in
masters programs phd programs to which i
say cool [ __ ] dose
it is
a real challenge and
it is um
very humbling i will say is one of the
things i'm truly recognizing is that to
be back in
a learning environment after spending
the last decade
eating pudding out of diapers
for views and calling it a job
it's humbling
i think i've only eaten
the pudding diaper situation one time
just to be clear
um but i'm sure the internet
obviously
can give you the facts on that uh
i've been working in youtube and content
creation for so long
was my only world it was the only thing
that i
knew how to do or knew how to be in
and i started to not know how to do it
or to feel like i didn't know how to do
it and feel like i didn't know how to be
in it
and so i needed something
outside of it
to potentially
re-stimulate ideas within it but
i'm in school
another thing that i've
realized about being back in school
is how vulnerable it is you really
don't know what you don't know until you
start to learn things that you
definitely don't know and that's how i
feel in school i've
you know kind of made this slogan for
myself i don't know online
um and you really you know thoughts are
things be careful what you manifest guys
because that has become very true for me
but
the vulnerable
exciting side of that is recognizing
what you don't know and how that can be
an exciting thing
versus a
um
degrading thing like i'm so stupid
no this is like i get to learn all this
stuff i didn't realize i didn't even
know
and see how the domino effect of it
reacting to the things i already know
and have experienced
what comes out then i i don't know
oh i've also learned by being back in
school a lot about my relationship with
procrastination
anyone out there a procrastinator yeah i
my name is grace helbig and i am a
procrastinator
um
me and procraster bffs but i realize
that they really bring out the worst in
me
procrastination for me is a bit of a
fickle temptress that tells me
perhaps your time is best spent
playing scrabble go all day every day
and though that sounds correct it is not
i've learned in practice
and that's kind of what i was doing
before i signed up for school i was just
sort of avoiding
existing
in a creative sense i was um
trying to run away from the friction of
it i was spending so much time just on
mindless
things sort of hiding from the world and
i needed to actually
challenge myself to participate again
and for me this was the best way to
start dipping my toe
back into it um
along with that a lot of people ask
questions about
how do you find motivation
to work or to study how do you find a
balance
and i recently talked about this with
memory
um on a bonus plot that we did
maybe it's weird to
talk about the other podcast you do
while you're doing one of the uh last
before break episodes of a different
podcast currently but
i don't know for me if hearing
um
the way other people handle their
procrastination necessarily helps
me but for those that it does help to
hear the way other people handle their
procrastination
um
i'm still figuring that out
i think the best way i can glean
uh that you can
deal with procrastination is to really
get introspective with yourself and
figure out
or at least start to try to figure out
what is the emotion that is causing
this
delay for me
to action
um
what ego
feeling is getting activated that is
trying to protect me
from doing whatever x y and z is that i
want to do but i can't find myself doing
i kind of think of it a little bit like
when you have all these tangled
um
headphone cords and you just sit when
you spend time sitting and actually
really untangling them that's kind of
the work
that you need to do to understand and
potentially
shift your relationship with
procrastination
that's all to say that i haven't totally
figured it out for myself i'm recording
this podcast now down in palm springs
because i
procrastinated on doing it up uh in los
angeles because i think i was scared of
wanting to make it perfect or
you know holding it on this pedestal of
having all this gravitas about it being
so significant to me and i want it to be
significant to you but then i also want
it to be candid and cool and casual and
that'll keep you from ever doing
anything at least for me
um
hopefully that helps procrastination
another big uh question as it pertained
to school was what do i plan on doing um
with this education in the future
and like i said i
don't want to do a clinical route
i can't be anyone's therapist this is as
close as i will get to that at least for
right now
uh but i can't see myself in that world
and
i i don't have any concrete ideas
at this moment of exactly what i'm going
to do and that's for me was one of the
challenging things i'm very much a
conclusion
kind of person i want to know
what
what's the thing i'm going to do
with this how can i use this and i think
that is so conditioned in me from making
youtube videos and content for so long
so you're constantly thinking about how
can i monetize this how can i um make
content out of this and it was so
wrapped up in like
how do i
make something for my career out of this
versus how do i just experience this and
so that for me is where i'm at i'm
trying to challenge myself to
be present in my schoolwork and
experience it and try my best without
worrying constantly about what
the benefit will be in the long run from
this because if i keep thinking in the
future i'm missing
the rewards in the present
easier said than done
take that as the whole through line of
everything i'm saying here that is easy
to say and intellectualize difficult to
put into practice and internalize
um but i'm hoping
that my education is helping support and
nurture my own creativity
um
i've really
learned that i like making things
and i love making people laugh
and
not being afraid to admit that for
myself has been huge and truly
was the foundation of why i ever got
into comedy in the first place and you
get really away from those core values
when you get in this world where there's
so much stimulus and so
and everything's so high octane all the
time
um
i feel like i had lost my soul
to social media
a bit and i'm i'm
trying to rediscover that through
academia now um if you come to any of
this might get weird live shows
you might be able to see me
doing a little bit more about that and
the
more uh formal comedy space
again sorry if it's strange to promote
stuff from another podcast on this
current podcast but
many plates
uh
which is a great segue into
a lot of questions that came in
about my thoughts on
youtube social media
um
where it was
where it's at now
i think
it's pretty obvious that this is
something i
have been obsessively thinking about
recently
as i ask almost every single guest
that's on not too deep about their
relationships with social media and
everyone seems to have a
heavy sigh
before they elaborate on how they feel
and that's
where i'm at too
more on that
after this quick break we'll be right
back with more not too deep
and me your host grace helvig with me
your guest grace elvig
[Music]
ah welcome back to not too deep with me
your host grace hellwig and me your
guest grace albig as i was saying
social media my relationship with it um
yeah i got very much into asking every
other guest that was on not too deep
about their relationship with it um
because i have my own personal
experience and thoughts on it but i uh
find comfort and interest and i have
such curiosity about how other people
are managing their relationships with it
and like i said
about every single guest had some sort
of
heavy sigh
complicated relationship with social
media and the ones that didn't i think
were like 19 so
they'll get there over time
uh okay social media
is a double-edged sword
in my opinion um
it has opportunities for connections
in ways that we could never feel before
um and with that it also
gives you a beautiful opportunity to
dissociate and distance yourself from
who
you are at your core
um
we get to share ideas
and art freely
and we also
in my opinion get to slowly start
coveting a false sense of worth and
identity
listen to this okay
the internet is a place where you can
be seen and scrutinized
entertained and empty supported and
sexualized cherished and cancelled
delighted and depressed obsessed and
overwhelmed nostalgic and numb all at
once
maybe that's just me
but
that is wild this place
is a tension of opposites there's good
there's bad there's uh everything in
between
can't recommend enough watching bo
burnham's inside he explains
his
relationship with social media
with comedy with entertainment with
performative arts
and performative
life uh
so viscerally
and wonderfully
viscerally
visceral word to say
um
yeah the internet and social media to me
are
a
beautifully dangerous place
for one's
ego for oneself for one's idea of
um
authenticity especially oh that word
that word
fills me with cringe these days i was
trying to figure out
kind of a hearkening back
to the self-help books that i've written
in the past which is still wild to me
that that's something i made and did
um
but i
in those books
used a lot of word play
for you to understand the really
important core concepts in it and i came
up with here that you can't spell
authenticity
without
thy anti-cutie
the shakespearean way of saying that
this over
arcing
overarching overarching
strive for authenticity
makes me feel like thy anti-cutie i
don't feel cute after a while of
desperately trying to figure out how to
be authentic i i feel like in the
initial stages of content creation
and internet dabbling
authenticity and transparency obviously
were the core ingredients to a
successful
interaction with an audience or a
successful
building of a brand that could be
trusted by people who could assume that
they understood exactly who you were and
they weren't being lied to or played or
anything like that but i get nervous now
that this idea of authenticity has been
so
diluted because
we're just trying to figure out how to
be authentic online versus just
being
um
and so the internet
oh here's whatever the internet
basically made me feel bad for a while i
think a lot of us are having these
dips in and out of the beauty and the
the beast of
interacting
in these mediums
someone asked me
about a piece of advice that i regret
putting out there
and i can't say
that off the top of my head i know any
piece of advice that i regret because i
forget everything immediately and tend
to repress
things that
um are regretful
but
i can say that i would
um
i would amend a lot of advice that i put
out there i had spent years being on
panel after panel at convention
after convention talking and squawking
and quacking about
authenticity transparency yadda yadda
blah blah blah
and i think i would amend with that that
yes those things
do
mean a lot when it comes to
being yourself in any capacity but
with that i think you should equally
honor
your own introspection
um
be as authentic and transparent with
yourself on why you dabble with the
digital devil
that's too harsh we'll call it a digital
demon um
i like the
i've started thinking like
no wonder it's called internet
world wide web
these are things meant to catch prey
from predators and i think a lot of us
can get
uh caught
in the web and the net um and lose a
real sense of the world and ourselves
it's also called the information super
highway or cyberspace and
i don't know about any of you but i
don't think i have the capacity
to successfully be on a super highway or
in space for long periods of time
so
i recommend
taking your breaks examining your
relationships with uh this medium and
really connecting to your why
why you're participating why what are
you getting um how does it make you feel
and no they if it doesn't feel good you
have a means to change that
again
easier said than done i'm still working
on
creating those boundaries for myself
understanding where to put those
boundaries and um and then you know
youtubing
how to set up a an emotional fence
thank god you can learn everything on
the internet right
um
okay i need everyone to look around real
quick because i think i lost my point
heyo
it's not all serious sobaki talk talk
squawk squawk uh but yes the internet
was making me feel
stuck and soulless i've already hit on
that many many many many many times
um
maybe this is the way that you feel uh
maybe you don't because you have a
better relationship with the internet
and that's great for you like i said i'm
still
experiencing and understanding it but i
do know that i couldn't experience this
type of bitterness for lack of a better
word without knowing the sweet taste
of how it felt to make content when i
started that was a
joyfully
pure era that i am so
thankful
to
have been
there
for
i'm talking you know
20 10
to
20 i don't know you know the 10 2010 11
12 13 14 those were some fun years and
thank you
for being around there for it if you
were there i'm sure you know this smile
and joy that i feel from it because you
do too it's hard to actually kind of
verbally transcribe
what that felt like um
but it's really really
sweet to look back on how
sweet it was and that's what made it
sweet is that you didn't even know in
that moment in those years how pure
everything was until it got a bit
tainted
again just my opinion
i also think with that that nostalgia
is a tricky thing at least for me
um
nostalgia for me is like really really
really
really old leftovers
really old leftovers
like they're best appreciated
for what they were in the prime state
that they were in but if you
keep trying to eat them you're gonna get
sick
and trust me this is a metaphor that i
understand
metaphorically and also literally my
gastrointestinal system uh has been
really eaten those nostalgic leftovers
for a long time which is also one of the
reasons that i i really wanted to go to
school and create new experiences
instead of you know dwelling so much in
the in the past
again i don't want to get preachy i put
in my notes a lot of times about not
getting preachy i think that's also due
in part to the sensitive nature that um
the internet has has become
don't want to say the wrong
thing
um
but let's dabble in a little bit of
nostalgia
a lot of people was a lot of people was
asking a lot of people were asking how
has not too deep changed over the eight
years
uh it's changed a lot i remember it
started in 2014
in response to rhett and link we're
doing a podcast and they were one of the
first people that i knew of that were
digital creators dabbling
in a podcast format
that
digital creators weren't really you know
expressing themselves in and their
podcast was very
personal very deep and so i wanted to
make the anti-version of that hence not
too deep and so it started completely
superfluous
just surface
only in the shallow end
um
in the
shallow and then that's where the song
stops
uh for me at that time and that was
great and very fun um but as i grew as a
person
and realized again that i you know find
people endlessly curious
i wanted to
start
wading into the deep end a little bit
um and really getting to know people
and also
when you realize that putting people on
the spot with
really arbitrary questions um
doesn't make them very comfortable
and as someone that really desperately
wants to make people comfortable and
seen i was doing myself a disservice by
kind of staying in that level so we've
gotten deeper over the years i'm sure
you noticed that if you have been
consistent listeners
people asked about my favorite guests
oh man we've had
349 episodes it's very difficult to
remember all of them but some standouts
for me
chelsea handler
bob saget was amazing
um john green
a recent conversation we had just kind
of talking about the internet
was very
nail on head for where
my
brain hammer was at with all of it um
and there's and so many more those are
just a couple quick that came to mind
but every conversation has been
has had something for me afterwards that
i've walked away going wow that was
really great
even if before we started recording i
was a nervous wreck or felt unprepared
or something
i realized too with all of this when i
was writing all this
that i do have such deep appreciation
for all the guests because really when
you zoom out and you think about
the experience of being a guest on a
podcast with a host that you
haven't met for the most part um
it's a wild situation to put yourself in
so
i have such
appreciation for strangers
trusting me to hold a safe space for an
unedited conversation for you know 45
minutes that's awkward and for people to
kind of put themselves in that
that's very cool and i'm very thankful
my natural resting state is anxious and
awkward so perhaps i have gotten a
little burnout on that aspect of it but
one of the biggest things i've taken
away from doing not too deep this was a
question someone had
is
the importance in life for seeing others
and for lifting them up which is a real
facet i've tried to infuse into every
episode is really making my guests feel
seen
um
if you have areas in your life that
you're doing that bravo if you have
opportunities to do that i couldn't
recommend it more
as someone that finds such um
sweet vulnerable joy and being seen and
appreciated
i
desperately
want to do that for others and this has
given me an amazing platform to be able
to do that so that really great
um
the other
biggest kind of
thing i've
appreciated and learned is the value in
staying
curious
to me curiosity comes without judgment
and to wonder is an act of generosity
to wonder without judgment about someone
is
a beautiful thing
uh and i'm thankful to have a space to
have done that here
and hope to do that more in the future
um
you know what else is
beautiful taking a break from this
sermon for a moment a moment
to get into some random questions
because that's how not too deep started
anyway
so
we're going to take a quick break
and when we get back
we're gonna wrap this episode up with
just some of the more lighthearted
questions that you guys
asked me on the social media so we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
not too deep
[Music]
and we're back just like that
um
man i really thought that i would have
to record this episode again and again
and again because i would get too
nervous that i haven't said things
correctly in the way that i want to and
that's maybe true
um there's a lot here that i've been
going through that again is like rough
draft thoughts that i probably could
write and say more about i was also
worried that this was gonna be
ten minutes
uh and it would breathe by but here we
are this deep into not too deep
and um thank you for listening to
basically kind of the sermon preachy
luxury um
he kind of thought
section of it again plenty more to say
there but maybe something was of value
and interesting for you now on to
just some quick hits
of
random questions you guys had someone
asked horror stories about making hello
fresh do i have any horror stories about
making hello fresh um not really horror
stories other than
i
uh chopped off the top of my thumb
cutting scallions
um one time
making a hello fresh meal and that has
stuck with me because it was a visceral
i felt like i had cut into a chunk of
meat which i did my skin thumb meat and
i won't
forget what that
oh sensation was like hasn't stopped me
from making hello fresh it also i think
was a little bit in part to the fact
that i was sipping on a weed cocktail
before that and that
might not have
aided in me being as present as i could
with the scallions and the knife which
also
lends itself into questions people asked
about me getting more into weed and
marijuana in the last couple years which
i have um
for me again
it's all just personal experience
preference thoughts i have enjoyed it
very much as a highly anxious a nervous
person that has felt in a very
changing place in their adult lives
where
it feels like
maybe nothing's happening but everything
is changing the best way i can
articulate that
uh and that produces a lot of anxiety in
me and marijuana has um helped me kind
of calm myself down
um
my
usual
kind of escapism route has always been
drinking and that i don't love as much
anymore and marijuana has been able to
allow me
just a little bit of a sense of of
calming down without being destructive
to say the least
um so i've really enjoyed it but i'm
also a bit of a puss about it and i'm a
pretty moderate weed smoker
mild i like the weed drinks because i do
still like the physical activity of
drinking i'll take a sip of my red bull
to confirm
gorgeous
but that's been really fun for me
um
and i
cannot believe how
broad and
amazing the weed and cannabis industry
is and it's growing like crazy in the
products i'm a sucker for products and
new innovations
freaking love shark tank and the whole
cannabis industry just feels like a
constant parade of new shark tank
products and i'd like to invest in them
all
for those reasons i'm in
um so that's where i'm at
with that i don't know if that even
answered any question
um
someone wants no qualities i seek in the
perfect snack food
oh it does play hand in hand to the
marijuana thing because i do find myself
quite the snack monster at night which
is my favorite endeavor to just be in
the comfort of my own home
now under a weighted blanket just
chomping away something that um
doesn't feed my soul feeds my actual
stomach uh and i love a crunch
i love chips i love eating cereal this
might be gross so you guys dry cereal
straight out of the box with my hands
like a little raccoon
that got into the airbnb and it's just
making the best of it um that's one of
my favorite things at night
so i like snack foods that offer
textural
elements that also i can eat with my
body utensils my fingers
uh someone wanted to know my thoughts on
aliens
um my thoughts on aliens are that
i
i don't think
well i don't have very profound
academically rigorous thoughts on aliens
other than i bet they're out there i bet
they're probably nice and super smart
and if they want to destroy us they
would have done it already um so who
knows but also i know that we don't know
[ __ ] about [ __ ] when it comes to
everything and that maybe people are
hiding information from us but who am i
to rule out any particular thing i like
to think of it that they're out there
and they're probably really nice
and those are my thoughts on aliens for
now
someone wanted to know if dogs were
pants would they wear them on two or
four legs
wow very intense question um
would dogs wear them on two or four legs
man if you don't get high and really
think about that because that is a
mental rubix cube that i don't know if
you can solve for yourself
uh i would say
i'm gonna go two legs
it's just my initial response because
seeing i've seen you know photos of the
dog so where the four-legged
onesies which look very cute and also
look
make them look very vulnerable
so i think out of dignity and respect to
dogs i will go two legs
but
front
uh someone asked would i ever be on
celebrity big brother answer is
absolutely hard no
absolutely not
i don't think i could ever be on any
reality program i think being on social
media is
being on an amateur reality television
show and it hasn't made me feel good
i don't have the brain capacity to be on
them but i do have the brain capacity to
enjoy them like i can go to an art
gallery and love all the paintings but i
couldn't do any of that and can you
believe that i just related reality
programming to fine art
i can because those are
the two worlds that my brain resides in
perhaps
and then
the last question
that we'll get into here because i don't
want it to be all pessimistic
uh my intentions are are good my
intentions are good with this episode
uh
someone wanted to know something about
the internet that makes me happy
well that's a lovely way
to spin this back up again um something
about the internet that makes me happy
is that it truly
has provided
like i said earlier
a means by which we can connect and not
feel alone
that we have never experienced before
i think
everyone
wants to feel some sense of connection
or understanding and the internet
really has been able to do that
um
in a way that you you couldn't before
that's not to say that there's that
could be too
risky
but you've already heard me talk about
that for the last hour uh
and that the internet gives um artists
and creatives
ways in which their work can be seen by
others that has never existed before and
i think it gives people that might not
have been
thinking of themselves as artists or
creators a way in which to see
themselves it just there are tons of
positives to the internet and there are
lots of negatives but this question's
about the happy things and i'm
really happy that it has allowed me to
create and
put myself out there in a way that i
look back and can't believe that i've
done
um and i i
truly
don't like i can't believe that i had
the
courage like to do so much [ __ ] for so
long when sometimes i feel so
lost and afraid and uh small and stupid
um and so i i encourage everyone
that has interest in making things
online to make things online and
everything that i have said about my
burnt current state of burnout
is only coming from my
current
years of experience around all of this
i'm sure again speaking to relationships
cultivating your healthy relationship
with it
um
is key
and
that segway is to
the future
what's going to happen in the future
uh i don't know
to keep the themes rolling i don't know
exactly what's going to happen in the
future this podcast will be taking a
break i'd like to finish up focusing on
school
with
less other things going on
and i'd like to process my school so
that i can
really be present for my future
as
paradoxical as that sounds um
so i don't know but
i hope you're here for it whatever that
might be
and
with that
i want to give some big thanks and if
you need podcasts to listen to
without not too deep there
obviously this might get weird this
podcast i do with my friend memory heart
comes out every wednesday and that will
still be rolling rolling
around i'm gonna get um
this is now gonna get taken down for
copyright infringement and i also
first of all
first of all we're at the end uh i wanna
say a huge huge thank you to melissa my
producer director you guys know her she
is absolutely incredible
and she produces and co-hosts uh
podcasts that you should absolutely go
put your ears and eyes on
in the meantime if you haven't already
also big shout out to diane
kang who used to be my assistant years
ago but has for the last few years been
working on this podcast with me in the
background she's created all of the
research
packets for every guest i have so
everything that i am able to know about
them she is
been providing for me throughout the
years and i can't say thank you enough
to her and she is now working with
melissa so go support that team of
wonderfully powerful incredible women
making great content that i think
you
should
and can
enjoy
uh
and then
lastly
a huge thank you to all of you
for
this i mean this sounds like i'm going
away forever it is that's not true uh
but i just have to be appreciative and
show how much
gratitude i have for you by saying it
here
that i'm so thankful for
you engaging with any of the things that
i've made over the years or in the
future where i'm right now thank you for
listening to this episode
it might have been a little
all over the place
maybe it made sense maybe it didn't
but it's there and it's done
ish
and i thank you for all of the sweet
wishes and sentiments you guys have sent
i'm learning to accept
sweet feelings and it does make me feel
vulnerable uh
but i i am so overwhelmed and thankful
for it and i wish you all the best
in doing the best you can because that's
all you can do
um
again thank you
i wrote out eight pages of notes and i
didn't write
any quippy way to end this episode so i
will just continue to ramble until the
end
thanks for listening to this episode of
not too deep
we'll see you next time
at some point in the near to distant
future goodbye
too deep too deep too deep
not too deep
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry and an
extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music